out of the gate it's another debate
about another mandate so how will it
rate who will meet their fate and who
will take the bait who will abdicate who
will acclimate who will constipate
president biden signaling a federal
crackdown could be coming for states
that don't follow his covet rules that
threat the latest example in a major
fight over mandates that is splitting
the country apart dana
biden and florida governor ron desantis
have been going after each other for
days over mandates like wearing masks in
schools desantis says it should be up to
the parents to decide but now the
president is looking into ways to
overrule states like florida
my concerns are
deep one of the things that i find
a little disingenuous
when i suggest that
people
in zones where there is a high risk
where the mass like you all are doing
i'm told that government should get out
of the way do you have presidential
powers to intervene in states like texas
and florida where they are banning mass
mandates i i don't believe that i do
thus far we're checking that
does that matter governor desantis is
defending his position and is refusing
to cave to pressure from people like
president biden
we're going to do whatever we can to
vindicate the rights of of parents and
make sure that parents are in the
driver's seat when it comes to the the
health education and welfare of their
kids and these should not be decreed by
the government this should be something
that a parent is ultimately making the
decision on and there's different
parents that feel differently about it i
respect that
but i think to force one way
is alienating and marginalizing a lot of
parents throughout the state of florida
so there you have it deagon so who is
the face of coercion here we you know
the president say it's governor desantis
but it's desantis who claims he's
creating the middle ground by saying let
the parents decide but then president
biden says no we're going to override
that so who's coercing who
well biden's not good at coercing
anybody
rhonda says this is mask optional okay
it's like i'm going to let the parents
decide and i know you're going to talk
about this later but there is no science
behind children wearing masks in fact
the hospitalization rate right now for
children is the same if not lower than
it was last year twitter's going to ban
you maybe youtube too yeah good luck
i have a way of coming back i'll find
i'll get you i've got a long memory um
how so joe biden you can kind of hear
him
hemming and hawing and doody do look at
the rainbow over there he doesn't really
know what he's uh talking about because
he's trying to figure out how to hammer
ron desantis but not make the mamas and
daddies in this important swing state
angry if you put them in a situation
where the the school district mandates
mask wearing and when i say biden is
kind of gasping and grasping he spent
all of last year blaming trump for the
highest death rates in the country here
in new york and in new jersey and now
it was he said i'm going to come in and
fix everything well he couldn't even get
his meet his target on the vaccinations
so he's kind of in no man's land and
notice he doesn't go after
the governor of louisiana
john bel edwards because he's a democrat
he has a mass mandate in the state but
the country has one of the lowest
vaccination rates and one of the highest
death rates in the nation and governor
john bel edwards now is invoking the
power of prayer and he's fasting
trying to help cure his state and
wouldn't that be the target of the left
if somebody if some republican governor
said i'm fasting i'm praying for y'all
yeah i fast and i pray for brian thank
you yeah good to see you uh amen i'm
lying yeah
i would can i just make a suggestion i
would take that same open for gut felt
yeah oh really right that's that's
strong how good it
[Laughter]
does this come out of my time yes no no
we're gonna take it out of her time okay
we're gonna give it to you she's gonna
learn i'm ready claiming my text yes
everybody claiming right there i
remember that but that was so much fun
uh
degan was talking about this is the
group of people who are least at risk
and yet we're mandating people are
mandating are we basically abusing
children to protect teachers
possibly i mean there is teacher
mandates out there there's uh individual
companies private companies that are
mandating now vaccines mandating mass i
get it people are scrambling to a corner
trying to figure it out meanwhile we're
also trying to play politics on top of
it i have news for you we're going to be
on the five a lap he has to fill in when
you turn an ankle or you run a fever at
some point and we're going to be having
the same debate for years to come
because it's going to be variant after
variant and how we handle it has got to
be a little bit more mature are we going
to have a national bedtime next where
nine o'clock joe biden proclaims by the
power vested in him saying with the holy
theme that we have to all go to bed at
the same time and it isn't amazing that
joe biden is actually postulating
whether he has legal authority to
mandate or override governors i have
retained a special lawyer andy mccarthy
and i asked him
legally does he have the ability to do
this and he writes
and i could not no that he does not have
the right to do this why are we battling
on this since when do parents need
permission to be parents parents went to
pick up when to when to put the kid in
corduroys even though all the other kids
are wearing jeans should they be fine
for that parents are in charge that's
the way it should be and i give broward
county a little bit of credit because
they said okay let's try to broker this
let's have a hope scholarship let's say
kids who don't want to do a mass mandate
will have be able to go to a private
school
for where they can do mass at liberty uh
for free so at least they're trying to
the whole state did that
they voted for it last week in uh in
florida yep you know austin we don't ask
loaded questions around here but i
wanted to just pose this to you why does
president bush brett biden
hate
parents
well why do parents love president biden
that's that's the reverse question look
the thing here is governor desantis is
trying to overrule the school boards in
florida so he's saying i forbid you
from requiring mass on top of he's had
you can't
you can't require the vaccine you can't
require testing
i think gold american nation
let's
that combination i think is a little
problematic i thought brian is right
that we're going to have variants we got
to figure out how we're going to
navigate this but it's a contagious
disease and we're not trying to make the
roads
easier and more open for drunk drivers
we're not trying to change the laws that
allow you to not have to clean up for
your pet if they if they make a mess and
kids are getting infected the pediatric
hospitals in florida are overwhelmed
and they spread the disease to each
other they're not even in school yet how
are you blaming the school yes i'm not
blaming the schools i'm saying there is
a risk at a time when florida's
infection rate if it were a separate
country it would be the highest
infection rate in the world that's a
moment where for a temporary period if
some school district in florida says
it's so high here let's wear mass for
the next two weeks
why is the governor saying no
i'm so confused by the statistics
because i i see that the case rate or
the hospitalization rate of kids is
roughly the same as it's been for a
while but the case load goes up and so
the media concentrates on the caseload
because that's the thing that's
mushrooming right yeah real quick the
cdc had to amend its florida covered
numbers because it was over reporting
the daily case numbers yeah i will shut
up now oh that's fine no dana there's
this uh concept that a brilliant
philosopher came up with it's called the
prison of two ideas
yes so you either have to be in masks
work or masks don't work we know that
masks aren't 100 effective there's
research out there but we also know it's
not zero right it's somewhere in the
middle but the news doesn't like that
right
they they they they like the two it's
got to be the it's got to be you got to
save your children or you're a murderer
but this isn't like seat belts no it's
it's it's something that there's a huge
gray area and that's kind of where
desantis is saying
who deals with the gray area not the
freaking law
the parents the gray areas for the
parents and i you've talked before about
um how you assess risk
right so for yourself and for your
children so if you're not if you're
being told that there's only two ideas
and you're a parent like well actually
we'll wait
and it gets a little bit overwhelming i
can imagine that there are some parents
who's like i want my kid to be masked or
even i want my kid in a remote school
because they their level of tolerance
for risk is really low yeah there are
other parents like everything i read
says that kids don't get very sick and i
think that the chances of him getting
hit uh when he walks across the street
if he doesn't look both ways that's a
higher risk so
that this whole debate is not allowing
for that the other thing is remember dr
osterholm who everybody really likes
he's at university of minnesota um he
was on air two weeks ago saying that
cloth masks don't work right and then so
rand paul says something similar and
then youtube bans him but they don't ban
dr osterholm and so
talk about the prison of two ideas it's
like if you
are
one doctor you can say it and be fine
and the other doctor gets banned it's a
it's also a weird one-way street about
the banning and censorship and the fact
that a a school board member can say if
children doesn't wear a mask she that
child will is committing murder as
somebody said oklahoma's later yeah she
did that
but but it seems like the censorship
only goes in one direction you can be uh
you can they can view you extreme in
your skepticism
but not extreme in your hysteria
although in this case desantis is saying
if you as a school board vote against
what i want i'm literally going to
confiscate your salary and you won't be
paid so i think it's a little bit of a
both sides are have got some extremists
why anybody bothered by governor murphy
though in new jersey who has mandated
statewide that there are masked in all
the schools but that's not overreach
i don't know
lots more to talk about hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else